hello freak [ __ ] well you definitely
do to play NFL there's no doubt about
diet I mean when you're staring down a
team of super athletes yeah and you're
just going to collide with each other or
try to get across lines yeah and just a
totally different way of living your
life's weird man in 99% of the world
I tell people like I've had 14 surgeries
in my career and it's just crazy like
it's normal to me and it's normal to
people playing the Liga I got the
decision like usually everybody gets a
surgery of something that that's been
what have you had done I've had meniscus
several times I've had Achilles back I'm
a pinky my shoulder actually played all
of my 2010 season with the broken
collarbone
Jesus Yeah right that game 3 and it
still burger you can still feel it but
with a broken collarbone yeah how do you
design mine old matter man it just is
like because it cuz I that's how I was I
want to draft right so it I had just got
my shot to start and it was game 3 and I
was having really good season and it was
either like if in the NFL if you're not
turned out I already paid like your
position is up for grabs and so it's
either either you push through it or
somebody's gonna take your spot Wow and
so at that does my smite that was my
time decide so I was like huge pain
killers man so could you feel it moving
around mm-hmm feels weird who had to
protect it my brother-in-law has like a
metal piece there
he lost his and a BMX accident see they
put like a titanium rod I think I need
that man cuz I right now is dipped in
you can feel it it's like dipped in did
you ever like you to look that not
because because I didn't want them to
know I was hurt and so because like they
bring that they bring that [ __ ] up like
during when you're negotiating a
contract cause I go but he missed it
because he was hurting they bring that
to use it as leverage against you and so
2012 is when I signed my contract the
day after I was like you guys want to
let you know I broke my collarbone two
years ago there's like no way house like
hit there's like no way so I get X
around and so we got x-rays like holy
[ __ ] you did and I would be impressed I
believe that's a guy I want on my team
yeah who'd played with a broken
collarbone it's bittersweet right so
like as soon as you tell them that
that's what happens then
I go he gets injured like it's a too
weird what he's human who the [ __ ]
doesn't get injured playing an NFL I
mean he would think that's the rational
way to go out bother you know anybody
who's played pro football didn't get
injured I mean how's it impossible I
don't feel like it was possible I
haven't seen anybody
I watched the Super Bowl and one of the
things when I was thinking was like okay
you're watching all these dudes run and
collide with each other and watch all
these tackles and like I was kind of
stockpile I was like in my head is like
how many injuries in my watching here
okay you know because a lot of times due
to walk off and then later that night it
like oh man my [ __ ] back is killing
me right man so and then you get a
diagnose and there's some sort of a
bulging disc or something the problem I
had because most of my issues that that
kept me off the field were like soft
tissue injuries which you can't I can't
run with a my hamstring won't get but
like all the rest of my stuff my problem
became like my pain my tolerance for
pain my threshold it became so high that
like I don't even know what what hurt
and what was normal anymore so like I'm
still kind of dealing with a lot of
those aches and pains and stuff now but
it's like you just push through it
because the pain was normal you just get
accustomed to it
yeah you just pain becomes a part of
life Wow yeah did you always know that
like when you were when you keep I'm
sure you played in high school when you
played college did you always know that
this was eventually going to lead to
like a point where your body that's what
I'm gonna be able to do it anymore I
mean you think about that
you said you say that all right and
people tell you about it but you know
they say ignorance is bliss you don't
know if it actually affects you until it
actually affects you and so like you're
like one of the worst games I've ever
been a part of whether you play in
Chicago and 2002 level I think and it
was raining and so they just running the
ball the whole game and the next day I
woke up like I'm limping like walking
towards the bathroom like I couldn't it
took me about five minutes and my
bathrooms like right there so it took
like five miles like literally like
limping my body was just beat up mmm
once the painkillers wear off from the
game and like when you go when you're
going through it you don't really
realize it but like towards the end of
my career that's that's kind of why I
decided to walk away because I was like
is it worth it anymore
you know sound relatively healthy I
could walk like a walk you know who
knows what I've done to my brain you
know that that the answer that comes on
years later but after a while it was
just stopped being worth it to me
anymore
plus I kind of just fell out of love
with it that's a weird place to be right
here now when you when you're saying
like you don't know what's going on with
your brain do you notice anything now uh
not nothing that has that haven't nah I
mean I've definitely had concussions
before and earlier on like the CT stuff
kind of um that was like - like that
product 2013/14 is when the science
really started and the news media
really started talking about it but
growing up like it was kind of just
called a dinger like he's got done and
so you got dinged and no one worried
about the matter so we didn't really
know and so it was just it was part of
it was part of it I've definitely had
concussions before where you like not
really sure where you are but like
somehow your subconscious knows what to
do when you play yes weird man so you're
out of it because you got cracked and
just kind of going through the game
anyway
keep going you remember it afterwards
parts parts mmm that's that happens a
lot to fighters like they'll get dropped
in the first round and then they'll be
on the corner in the like the fourth
round like headed into the fifth and
they'll think it's the second round -
and then the coach will go hey man you
fought three more rounds and you think
you did it like what yeah
it's crazy the second round right like
knows the last time the [ __ ] are you
talking about and it's crazy it's
amazing to me that people are able to
function on such a high level not really
conscious of what's going on that's got
to be your training right yes that's all
training is your training your body to
become second nature so now when you
were in high school and you were in
college was there any talk at all about
brain damage was there any talk about
CTE or the not really nobody worried
about it and I was just not it wasn't it
was the science wasn't completed I'm
pretty sure they were they were
neuroscientist saying like your brain
damage is real but the science wasn't as
definitive as it is now right but no one
connected it the way they did with
boxing not to us and that's me you know
it like
like now people are worrying about
putting their kids in youth leagues and
stuff yeah and even talking about not
letting these things happen
I have tackle football which I'm an
advocate for I don't think there's a
there's no point for it like my kid my
sons are not gonna play football
I know oh why not raise but you you made
it my body so so they can have a free
rider whatever they want to do what if
they want to play football
i'ma say sit down man you got trust like
merrylegs yeah what if they want to be
their own man you know okay I'm not
gonna physically I've been I'm not
probably could but I would I would I
would seriously sit him down and and let
him know the consequences showing people
and show them that the risk factors
involved like it is not worth it I know
you wanna and I mean as much as the son
wants to walk in his father's shoes it's
just not worth it man right it's really
night and you're probably not going to
be as good that's just how what if you
kid won in the fight like a bot like box
yeah a boxer kickboxer I mean I made
like I wouldn't advocate that easy you
wouldn't let them do it now I'm pushing
them to go towards like education now I
want them to be scientists like if I had
to do it over again I wouldn't ever play
football I really yeah besides nothing
you would start from the beginning like
if you could go back to college and
knowing what you know now
Wow not even close and just because the
damage to your body
well that and uh so it's a weird it's a
weird thing so like you're you're in
your prime physically as a man but
you're in your infancy mentally all
right right and so like I'm just now
figuring out who I am and what kind of
man would be and you're you're why
you're in your prime that's when you're
in the public eye so you have to deal
with all of that on top of figures so
you're figuring out who you are
and fishable and it's a really weird
really weird thing so I don't even want
to do like any kind of recognization or
any kind of Fame or whatever people are
called it I don't I don't like it I
don't want it I feel like the best to me
that the best society would be artists
the scientists that would be a ideal
society to me wow that's an interesting
take on considering how successful
you've been playing football I mean
playing football obviously was very
financially rewarding for you made you
famous for sure
I mean if just some regular dude went on
Twitter and started talking about I can
take a wolf or nobody killed a flock
nobody okay if you're like shut up
stupid I'm not I doubt anybody cares
anyway but it all be talking my Twitter
exploded when I said you were coming on
like you would at school my words oh
come on man Wow cool shot a wolf man was
gonna kill fairway
[Applause]
[Music]